welcome to this video I am Wilson
palencia two games I have played against
them one win one loss it is going for
this line okay I recently learned that
this is a viable so I'm just trying this
without knowing anything that new five
in the exchange variation of the rib is
really funny because black black has
played and tried like every move really
everything that makes sense and maybe
some moves that don't make any sense so
I'm going to cancel along here quickly
so i could probably have six I can do d4
has long castles that looks wrong for
white let's cancel long oh it's got good
night em night Bishop e3 should have at
least paid any paid some attention to
that okay so yeah where do i go to e6
probably six so d3 let's go ahead let's
just develop stuff and see how is
handling this pin down I this somewhat
annoying oh really I choose 649 f4 ones
that surprising so let's jump right in
okay Queen a 70 set a move now okay can
take a three so Queen a seven isn't any
good advan is way low by the way yep
Venezuela and so no Queen ASAP please
and under those circumstances so way for
a seagoing b4 b5 maybe yes okay I'm
going to push myself and just wonder if
I go it's not g4 it's not threatening
much it's not threatening that much
jackets try like this and take a look at
b5 and 92 I have to irritate them here
with this cannot allow simple b5 coming
maybe I can still go G for next ok ok
let's let's push c 3 9 p-3 I don't
believe and be 50 I have to take it at
hope it works out
now it will be dangerous that that much
is clear c6 night away and then some c4
stuff coming danger is it will be six
doesn't look good nigel form still going
c3 and I'm depending on that gphone
bishop here wow wow that is a pretty
probably just losing this position
amazing
hmm okay
yeah not exactly enthusiastic about this
move but maybe be six or a bit more
conservative I know it just looks
terrible it just looks like it's no good
c3i maybe you can just go click oc3 nazi
to Quincy five or something it's hard to
believe that I can survive the
disposition really hard to believe
hmm
yep it doesn't I mean if I think for a
long time now it probably won't help so
is there some kind of counter tech like
Bishop f3 or something should we have
three Knight takes Queen g4
Jim
now move back here it's probably losing
anyway and this is actually not night
cakes okay I mean it doesn't really
matter right Knight takes should should
win GTX is not working Knight takes
Queen g4 so um rook g2 is not going to
work due to 94 i guess i can take and
the screen is attacked actually time
morning
94 probably
94 84 Queen f3 group g4 yeah it does
lose somehow but at least that sets up
problems King takes well I can check him
book g8 king of one check their king you
1 it's maybe not even that clear and I
can check on g4 type check check added
wolf I didn't think about might might
win of course for him some work g8
things
it takes this I'm going to retake going
to recapture we have three Queen no
lights is six and [ __ ] and they shoot oh
we didn't do that that's surprising um
check
check check I have no time and I've got
my two pieces down hahaha check okay we
have three made my forehead honey I
could have taken that night gay crazy
game crazy game now came this are
probably uh nesta mated it felt really
weird that he allowed my night to
forward his counter tech is quite strong
I probably have to have to do something
else here g5g for stuff is just bad
probably am you know something like this
and Bishop here so that i can take here
in case of B form it's probably probably
am a decent idea just be solid yeah that
Jeep on push and so on that didn't do
any good oops I'm sorry check yeah this
is probably relatively good at first Wow
computer actually thinks I'm okay at
least they're on a low depth this again
gives b6 yeah maybe rook be too was the
best move and I'm losing him there from
the heavy five was a bit too strong that
too strong a method yeah and he okay I
knew that this wouldn't work but slow
moves also don't work so
yeah an iteeche towards a good defense
really defended this as well a keen 96
was a bit stronger but check check okay
was a funny game thanks for watching